versatility something everyone strives
for especially Rog who releases a ton of
products with small to game changing
twists on a pretty regular basis
actually if you check out the really
schedule it's always stacked the Rog
Ally is their first Champion to enter
the arena of handheld gaming PCs and it
boasts some pretty powerful chipsets the
AMD Z1 and the Z1 extreme that
definitely blow the steam deck that is
really due for an upgrade out of the
water given how the steam deck is only
available in select regions and the Ally
being available pretty much everywhere
is the Ally really worth it for your
average Joe or someone who is totally
new to the handheld World we're going to
kick things off by talking about battery
life both the Rog Ally and steam deck
are great for your daily commute and by
daily commute I mean like a 40-minute
trip to the office an hour if you're
pushing the consoles and charging it
when you hit the office but that also
depends on what your play and the power
options you're on for the Ally in
particular it's three power options
turbo performance in silent run at 31
words 25 watts and 15 watts respectively
also the Ally and steam deck both have a
40 watt battery real world test wise I
played dark tie on both devices on
medium settings the Rog Ally achieved 45
minutes of gameplay on turbo mode at a
steady 30 to 40 FPS I tried performance
mode and capping the fps to 60 and
changing the resolution from 1080p to
720p and that got me an hour and 10
minutes FPS doesn't stay at a steady 30
sometimes it goes up and fluctuates
between 30 to 44 FPS but for the most
part you're looking at about 22 to 30
FPS whereas the steam deck are an hour
and 15 minutes at a relatively steady 25
to 30 FPS which is surprising because
you think the newer Hardware will do
much better but also not surprising
because some games are optimized for the
steam deck and the steam deck does not
have to worry about any other app except
steam those reasons are probably why the
steam deck will do better and play more
consistently than the Ally obviously it
differs from game to game but this is
what I found I'm of the safe opinion
that these windows based or Linux in the
steamedex case handheld gaming console
slash PCS aren't particularly great with
battery life you can get some Triple A
gaming out of this but after playing a
match of model of a 2 on tailbone
settings for the Ally you're gonna need
to charge it up or stay plugged in only
time will tell how great the battery can
take sustained periods of play while
plugged in by this I mean it bloating
and whatnot especially if you're looking
for an alternative to getting a PC which
I know many of you are thinking I mean
you should get a PC if you can if you
want sustained periods of gameplay I
really suggest capping your FPS 30 being
selective of the games you want to play
and fiddling around with the graphical
settings and in the case of the Ally
change it from 1080p to 720p for the
first offer of its kind from Asus Rog
it's a great effort this thing could
definitely beat out a PS4 at its own
game in the case of the steam deck you
can change out the power options and
anything though not as straightforward
as the Ally and you're not really going
to see stunning graphics on this but it
works the Ally may have 10 hits at this
juncture but there's also the whole
thing with app and UI compatibility and
optimization that the steam deck already
has but we'll get into that later on
graphically intense games aren't great
for these handhelds like the if you're
playing emulators on either the steam
deck or the Ally you've probably got no
issues with either one thermal
management wise the fans on this theme
that kick in like a fighter jet on
pretty much any game
it goes pretty hot and hot and pretty
loud I was afraid I burned my eyebrows
off Jokes Aside it's not great the Rog
Airline on the other hand is much
quieter though it's only relatively
quieter in turbo mode compared to the
steam deck
we'll be talking about performance and
silent mode yeah it's definitely way
quieter and also as a bonus and if
you're wondering I did try out the
external GPU device with the LI the XG
mobile where again you are slapping a
RTX 490 onto the Ally which makes it
quite the devil of a handheld station
and yes it does heat up a lot more than
playing it handheld I'd say the airflow
would feel similar to that of the steam
deck it's heavy and heated the display
on the Ally is way better than the steam
deck any day of the week 1080p 120 hertz
is really cool for handheld though those
specs will be even more useful after
more games or launches are optimized but
for now it makes crushing bodies and
flying guards look very pretty the steam
decks display does the job and that's
really the best way to put it you want a
game you got a game any screen at 720p
60hz and that's decent enough
temperatures on the steam deck are
definitely much worse than the Ally Rog
is known for their Innovations for
thermal management management and the
Ally is no exception playing Dark tie
with the Ally at 720p 60hz on
performance mode it stayed at a steady
60 degree celsius and the steam deck at
a steady 80 degrees Celsius it's a world
of a difference you've got Mustafa on
one end and pause on the other and the
colorways fitting me so in the
ergonomics actor I really like the feel
of the steam decks handles I've got a
firmer grip and as I mentioned in my
initial impressions of the Rog Ally you
can check it out here I hope either Asus
Rog or someone out there makes
aftermarket cases with the handles like
my switch because it will make me like
the Ally a lot more in this department I
found that I can play slightly longer
without feeling discomfort with the
steam deck thanks to its back grips
since I have more console to grip on but
it doesn't negate hand cramps in any way
I mean yeah but when it comes to weight
and overall design I would still give it
to the Ally It's travel friendly Compact
and like the the Ally feels like an Xbox
controller the steam deck a PlayStation
both of which are great because my
muscle memory kicks in and I adjusted
them pretty quickly both the triggers
and joysticks feel fine but I think they
could do a lot better with the buttons
on the Rog Ally because they do feel
wobbly but if you don't care about these
kind of things between the two the Ally
is a great introduction to the wonderful
world of handheld PCS or consoles also
between the two the Ally looks so sick I
mean it's so cool also fun fact they do
they designed this is Singaporean
some Singaporean Pride for you and
before we continue this channel is
supported by Brands who help us improve
our content and keep us going so stay
around for this sponsored message meet
this
check out this translucent material
design that not only looks good but
feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12th
gen Intel Core i7h Series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its nahi big twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com now the Ally is
essentially a PC with some Asus Rog
Armory crate integration though it is
not the smoothest after spending some
time with it the Armory crate does feel
janky here and there sometimes some
games won't properly register the Allies
Gamepad and only does so after some
fiddling and sometimes I can't tell
whether the performance modes are
actually engaged the Ally needs some
changes to its software integration with
Windows but this is where the steam deck
shines because it's solely focused on
being optimized for steam or steam's big
picture which makes the user experience
so much more seamless though you're
going to be stuck with theme for life
for real though I still have like 300
games I haven't touched it you can go
into desktop mode but for the Ally it's
literally a PC I can have steam bet on
that and epic games all running on the
Ally though not the smoothest experience
for the most part because none of them
are truly optimized for the Ally I do
like having that versatility to my
console to play whatever and any game I
want it's a trade-off versatility in the
games you have but it's janky as of this
video or a smooth but limiting
experience for both valve and RNG these
are the first devices out there and
you'll definitely never hit the mark on
the first try and these devices are no
exception to that I think that Rog
trying to outdo what Zelf has with the
steam deck is more than a good effort in
no way is this perfect but I think I
stay true to what I originally said
about the Ally over the steam deck that
I would definitely prefer it anytime but
do I think this is a great entry point
for someone like you and I on the street
if you can't afford it I will go with
the rot Ally cost of availability and
price but don't forget there are also a
ton of other console tools on the market
that make Ken house just like these but
of course if you want to get one like
right now and jump on the train I'd go
with the Ally the more important
question is what do you think would you
get the Ally or will you enlist into law
Cuban's Evergreen Army and battle it out
with pretty much the rest of the world
let me know in the comments below if you
have any questions about either device
and make sure to follow us on all of our
socials right here to keep up to date
with everything we put out and maybe
subscribe to us it goes a long way in
helping the channel out and if you want
to see more stuff check this out
[Music]
thank you